passer à la deuxième petite annonce on
continue avec kevin a annoncé
jean-michel au nom il a essayé de
trouver la tuque il
asca prison michel là c'est pas triste
yahoo mais là aussi la crise et des
caddies non non j'ai retrouvé regardez
là c'est le comédien qui parle regarde
salut à tous ce qu'est mina bon bah
voilà je voulais lui dire je suis bon
goûter
vendredi c'était avec mon bail frère
pour fêter nos trois heures de relation
et la bible dans koh lanta je découvre
qu'ils ont viré une candidate qui était
trop rigolade qui sont trop bien en
peluche sur bout de ma life dont vous la
sphère revient dans le jeu ok bon je
vous laisse j'ai un cours de langue avec
mon mec
art est franchement attendez que je sois
mort pour faire ça ça fait de la peine
jean moi que tu lis le tag au pardon est
ce que je pourrais m'occuper ton
héritage artistique je sais pas si j'en
suis pas sûr encore alors qu'elle est
l'info et jean-luc c'est julie qui s'est
fait éliminé de koh lanta
julie qui s'est fait éliminer de
commenter samedi
ah oui c'était vous c'est assez facile
c'était le lancement de koh lanta le
combat des héros et pour son grand
retour l'émission a terminé leader des
audiences
même si le score est en baisse 1
maximalisme perdu cinq cent mille
téléspectateurs et autres éléments de
comparaison le lancement de la
précédente saison all star faisait ses
millions s'est passé et là ils en ont
fait quatre millions d'âmes le week end
bien de faire ça allait tout donner sauf
l'audience à bercy une audience
calamiteuse une audience de seconde zone
pour un casting de seconds rôles d'ados
région je vous l'avais dit ça ne prend
pas n'y a pas d'intérêt et ça va c'est
furet je vais vous dire énorme et je
vais vous dire vous êtes dur parce que
moi j'ai trouvé ça vraiment très bien
enfin après vous allez dire ce que l'on
pense et on commence donc avec julie ces
thèmes c'est une candidate qui avait
participé à koh lanta l'île au trésor ce
qui la détermine le plus c'est sa joie
de vivre un jeudi vendredi dernier elle
a été éliminée mais est encore très très
en forme
julie julie julie
c'est neil des rouges ni l'île des
jeunes je me dis que ça me laisse la
chance de continuer l'aventuré en fait
58 champagne on dirait une piña colada
et il a loupé des choses des entrées
session on ne s'ennuie pas mais moi et
kozani pas bernard qu'est ce que tu
aimes pas eu de carlo bernard lani toi
alors sur twitter
chacun de faire le buzz ils ont tiré du
lit c'est comme si tu es la maman de
bobines deuxième au village unies
d'entrer jeu et déjà les jaunes koh
lanta alors elle n'est pas vraiment viré
parce qu'elle valait oui à la semaine
prochaine il faut pour nom le prénom la
dans l'aventuré oui il ya un problème
c'est que là c'est une façon de
contrôler un peu les traitements à celui
de l' aventure parce qu'effectivement la
production pour apprendre des jeux en
fonction des aptitudes des uns et des
autres c'est très dangereux
ah oui comme j'aimerais en colère
j'attends que la date où est-ce que tu
regardes je regardais avant ça je sais
pas s'ils avaient regardé tu regardes
avant koh lanta 4g décrochant pas
pourquoi ça y est tu as ta potable tap
le tout est 7,7 chauffe plus non ça me
sinon on n'a plus le temps
maintenant vous savez garder une fille
maintenant on a autre chose à faire mais
ça tape longvic quoi ça y est ça ma ça
m'intéresse plus comme avant moi j'ai
grandi j'ai grandi un peu avec eux
lantabat rien sur avec koh lanta mais sa
maman franck et puis à -2 ya moins d je
trouve qu'il ya moins de vie trouve
termonde failli péter mendell fight pour
moi les des personnages ça fait combien
de temps que ça existe ça c'est à 18,6
fatigue peut-être ça marche toujours
bien fait 5 millions de téléspectateurs
alors y avait aussi à signer les
participer à koh lanta cambodge à
l'année dernière
et une fois encore y affine a
impressionné tout le monde par ses
capacités yassin isse étouffé en regarde
ça veut dire quoi pure et que je vais
avoir un toit pour dormir
il vous a impressionné dans son aventure
yacine sur le camp ah ouais moi me fait
penser est toujours actif
vous pouvez le maintenir proche que
maintenant je vais juste prendre la
mesure
attention à la bulle
c'est pesant
c'est le premier totem
je vais leur mettre à yacine parce que
c'est yacine qui permet à cette équipe
déroule de remporter cette première des
victoires bravo les filles
il ya six mois je suis à fond avec lui
mais sûrement la meilleure saison en
terme de narration serait que les 18
candidats issus des onze saisons ne
reviennent pour une revanche nains qui a
perdu au poteau la première fois un qui
est éliminé de manière outrageuse
mais en fait et en matière de casting
c'était assez incroyable c'est clément
en avril 2007
la prod envoie un mail à 350 candidats à
peu près ils ont les retours il
sélectionne une soixantaine et sur ses
60 ensuite il y voit un parent armes
pour leur poser des questions québécois
voulait vraiment venir quel était ce
faisant vous voulez venir quels sont les
figures les plus marquantes de koh lanta
et après c'est toujours comme ça ils ont
sélectionné une trentaine alors il avait
la passion comme ça mais oui c'est pas
la première fois que oui mais pour ce
qu'ils ne savent pas ce alors c'est beau
c'est loin il n'y a pas de riz ils sont
aguerris
c'est fidji en fait moi je trouve que
trop de koh lanta tulle koh lanta en
inversant d'être encore sur les poteaux
vous avez pas besoin d'être encore sur
un poteau programme long sur 1 foot
français ont signé ça ressemble à une
sorte de halte garderie un peu à la télé
réalité à la société la réalité comme
dans les anges en fait on recycle des
vieux champion wpt est étrangement moi
je trouve que c'est ennuyeux ni moi je
suis complètement de la vie de gilles
pour une grillade des poteaux
l'événement l'événement de vendredi
aussi les grandes séquences qui fait le
buzz sans vous le vouloir clémentine a
montré ses fesses alors les twittos se
détestent encore et toujours clémentine
voilà a démenti mais chez les jaunes
eh bien allez les rouges bon mdr alors
tu fais tu me fais faire dix sept mille
kilomètres pour découvrir que je dors
sur une page avec tes menti j'éteins mon
flambeau moi même en arrivant voilà donc
les gars sont vraiment à leurs gardes
clémentine fonce
mais clémence et rita leers
soit
[Applaudissements]
ça me rappelle l'arrêt de leurs deux cas
de l'area khadr alors koh lanta ce que
ça va remonter ou est-ce que ça va pas
se blesser au même niveau
vous les premiers épisodes toujours un
peu fait le même si là on connaît déjà
les candidats je pense à ma montre monte
un peu d'avancé sur la saison est d'ores
et déjà ratée à chaque petit rab
alors je sais pas c'était toujours
négatif en fait c'est quoi un objectif à
objective négatif
ouais physiquement ça va monter ya un
partenariat caveau certaines de dourdan
bon bien que ça rabaisse n ya aucune
surprise c'est plus intéressant du tout
la lui les leaders
les sages ou baroudeur et ya peu de
surprises a abaissé à la poutre oui un
avis stagnation en easy stagnation
enlisement ces pyramides ici combien
attendu non je pensais rester dans ces
zones là autour de 4 millions 5,5
millions moi je préfère a monté sa
fausse engagé chacun jouera pas ce soir
arte regarde je regarderai vous vous
aimez toujours abaisser ses lourds en a
marre moi aussi et je regardais quand
j'étais plus jeune mais ça y est ça y
est ouais vous rendez vous en avez votre
claque à la casquette
alors on va regarder regarder les
internautes j'ai maté 41% juste après we
will show parce que même si la resega
beaucoup et longtemps koh lanta